Speaker 1: But let's try going to Aubree from
Wisconsin, if we can. Aubrey from Wisconsin,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2:
Hi. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 2: And I quote both. So I've spoken to you
before, like, once, but. Okay. Sorry. I have one
question for you. I don't know what to ask, but
I was curious. What is your use on like this in
cell culture? Because, like, I think, like, it
kind of rose about with the internet. So, like,
I'm like hella old Gen Z, right? So like,
I just turned 24, which is super cringe.
Speaker 1: But it's cringe to be
24. AUBREY What does that mean?
Speaker 2: It's a cool I'm old, right? Like,
I look when I turn 35, I'm going to get,
like, five. I don't know. Like.
Speaker 1: So whenever you swear,
we have to bleep it. So please try to
limit the swearing and producer. Pat,
please make a note. We've got to censor
that. We've got to bleep that. Aubrey,
did you once call in and even though you're from
Wisconsin, it sounded like you had a Long Island
accent? Is that who you know?
Speaker 2: We hang out. Okay.
Speaker 1: I remember you. I remember you.
Speaker 2: All right. That's so cute. Romantic.
No. Okay. So I want to know what your view
of, like in cell culture is, because, like,
these radical people are cringe and weird, like
Kevin Samuels, who, like, always talked down to
women and basically told them, you know, you're
never going to find a man, you're going to die
at 35 because you think you deserve to die
better. And then he ended up dying alone,
making love to a random woman, you know what I
mean? So I just wanted your perspective on that.
Speaker 1: Okay. Here's I don't know about the
people you're mentioning, but here's my I actually
did a segment on the Wednesday show about Incel
culture. Here's the thing. Incels are often seen
as failures in society. They're made fun of and on
and on and on. And I think that this is really the
wrong approach, particularly because it's. Part of
the whole Incel thing is extremely anti-social in
a way, and sometimes the incels end up committing
acts of violence like we've seen elements of incel
interwoven into sometimes mass shootings and
other events. So I believe we actually need to
reach out to Incels and we need to actually work
with them. And I don't know whether it's therapy
groups or what it is, but we need to really
provide the resources to both develop skills
and build confidence, because a lot of it is
a self-fulfilling prophecy where the incels
lack confidence and then they're made fun
of. So they're even less confident and then
they can't get. You know, typically it's like
heterosexual men that women won't talk to. They
get more depressed. So we need to do we need to
do something. I think it's they're highly targeted
and often made fun of, but I think we actually
need to be doing more to help the Incels know.
Speaker 2: Okay. I respect that.
Right, completely. Yeah, but
no, I mean, not like listen, write things I don't
love and stuff, right? Like, it's like these
people who think they deserve sex. Oh, we women.
Speaker 1: I agree. Let me make a declaration.
There is a small portion of people who think
the way to solve incel is to force women to
have sex with the incel men. I do not think
that that's the solution. I think that's crazy.
Speaker 2: Okay. Good. I'm
glad we cleared that up.
I just want to say that to any men online who are
listening to this, do not tell a woman she is an
ugly whore just because she does not want to
go out with you. Cringe. Weird. All right.
Speaker 1: Very important advice and useful,
hopefully to many people in our audience or maybe
in other audiences, I don't know, necessarily
to mine. Aubrey, great to hear from you again.
Speaker 2: Right. Okay. Thank you.
Speaker 1:
I don't know if Aubrey who Aubrey is laughing at,
but a lot of laughing going on there. All right,
folks, let's take a very quick break. We're
not ending calls. So if you want to get on,
just hold on, because we're going right
back to the discord lines in a moment.